تصاعد التوترات في الشرق الأوسط مع
قيام الطائرات المقاتلة الأمريكية بسلسلة من
الضربات في العراق ضد حزب الله،
أحد وكلاء إيران الإقليميين، قالت الولايات المتحدة إن
ضربات يوم الاثنين استهدفت
منشآت الطائرات بدون طيار التي تستخدمها الجماعة المسلحة
والمعزعون التابعون لها وهم
يقودون موكب جنازة
عبر  شوارع
بغداد حيث قالت القيادة المركزية الأمريكية إن
الضربات على الأرجح قتلت عددًا من
المسلحين أمر الرئيس جو بايدن بشن
الضربات بعد أن أعلن كتاب حزب الله الذي
اعترفت به الولايات المتحدة
كمنظمة إرهابية مسؤوليته عن
هجوم الطائرات بدون طيار يوم الاثنين على القوات الأمريكية في
العراق، مما أدى إلى إصابة ثلاثة أمريكيين.
وقال أعضاء الخدمة في البنتاغون إن من بينهم جنديًا
في حالة حرجة في بيان،
وقال مجلس الأمن القومي إن
الرئيس لا يضع أولوية أعلى من
حماية الأفراد الأمريكيين
الذين يخدمون في طريق الأذى،
وستتصرف الولايات المتحدة في الوقت وبالطريقة التي
نختارها.
تستمر هذه الهجمات، وقد تم استهداف القوات الأمريكية في العراق وسوريا
حوالي 100
مرة منذ أكتوبر عندما
بدأت حرب حماس مع إسرائيل، وحاولت الولايات المتحدة
معايرة ضرباتها الانتقامية
لإرسال رسالة إلى وكلاء إيران في
المنطقة دون إثارة
حرب أوسع نطاقًا الشهر الماضي.  كما نفذت الولايات المتحدة
ضربات ضد كتيبة حزب الله في العراق مما أسفر عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن ثمانية من مقاتليهم
وفقًا للجماعة. وقد أدانت الحكومة العراقية
كلا الهجومين
ووصفتهما بالأعمال العدائية
غير المقبولة تحت أي ظرف من الظروف،
ولم تقتصر الاضطرابات على
الأراضي فوق العراق.  في نهاية الأسبوع، ضربت الولايات المتحدة
بطائرة بدون طيار هجومية أحادية الاتجاه تم إطلاقها مباشرة من إيران
ناقلة مواد كيميائية في
المحيط الهندي، ولم تكن هناك سفن تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية في
المنطقة المجاورة، ولم يتسبب الهجوم في وقوع إصابات،
لكنه أثار حريقًا على السفينة
وفقًا للقيادة المركزية لأنها
أثارت مخاوف من  صراع أوسع
تحاول الولايات المتحدة تجنبه،
وتقول القيادة المركزية إنه وفقًا
لتقييمها الأولي للغارات الجوية الأمريكية
في العراق، لم يكن هناك أي مدنيين
متضررين، لكن الحكومة العراقية
تقول إن هناك 19 شخصًا أصيبوا بجروح،
جندي واحد تقريبًا و18
آخرين من بينهم مدنيون، لذا  وهذا
جزء من سبب غضب الحكومة العراقية
من هذه الضربات مرة أخرى، حيث
تعتبرها أيضًا انتهاكًا
للسيادة العراقية، وهي نقطة مهمة
هنا لأن الولايات المتحدة تعمل مع
قواتها في العراق بدعوة من
الحكومة العراقية أورين ليبرمان سي إن إن في
البنتاغون